you call your ex right now and she
answers I'll give you 20 bucks if he's
not calling his ex get the [__] out get
the [__] out it's like an easy 20 bucks
no I don't care the easiest 20 bucks you
ever made in your life can I call my ex
sure wait what do I have to call my ex
wait so he can't call his ex but you can
call your ex have the answer yeah do I
got his number
still
and he answered
mhm
hello oh sh he answered it's just the
hello I've come to with you again now
how respectful are you of your boyfriend
if really and truly it takes $20 for you
to publicly disrespect him guys respect
is love to men and these public
humiliation rituals for men really have
to go and have to stop